[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno a tutti volevo prima che
prima di cominciare questo mio discorso
voleva che tutti quanti noi facessimo un
po di casino applaudiamolo diamoci tutti
bravo più casino frutta chino viviamo
[Applauso]
grazie e ora e ora stiamo in silenzio
per 15 secondi ogni conto perché di
solito sforo sempre
perfetto perché il silenzio perché il
primo muro da abbattere il muro del
silenzio il muro del silenzio che ogni
giorno ci accompagna nella nostra vita
quotidiana appena la sveglia suona la
mattina ci ritroviamo da soli con noi
stessi davanti davanti allo specchio con
le nostre contraddizioni e vorrei qui
parlarvi un po della storia della mia
vita ma anche di tante storie di comuni
di persone che sono diventate
straordinarie personalità magari
qualcuna di qualcuno abbiamo mai sentito
parlare voglio cominciare con una storia
lucana e precisamente in un piccolo
paese nova siri e vorrei far sentire
questa musica questo jingle
[Musica]
grazie mille
parliamo della storia di nicola che
l'autore di questo brano
nicola è uno dei più grandi compositori
italiani del nostro tempo
tantissimo in italia non lo conoscono e
vincitore di diversi premi
internazionali e lavora spesso per
marvel
avete sentito le colonne sonore di
alcune colonne sonore di spider man
eccetera sono appunto sue
e questo il frutto di un lavoro che
parte da una lotta interiore dallo
sconfiggere il muro del suo silenzio di
una sua storia che la lotta contro una
leucemia infantile che gli avrebbe
impedito impedito di vivere dopo pochi
anni ma lui ha cominciato a combatterla
a sconfiggerla e nello stesso tempo a
parlarne apertamente con con le persone
che lo circondano
perché volevo cominciare da questa
storia perché la prima cosa da fare per
chi vuole comprendere se stesso e il
mondo rispetto alla concezione della
propria libertà e rompere il proprio
muro del silenzio il proprio muro del
silenzio nella nostra vita quotidiana
io cominciai la mia attività
per la lotta per i diritti umani nel
2000 quando appunto mi svegliai un
giorno è la mia parte inferiore del
corpo non funzionava più
naturalmente essendo un personalità
psicosomatica che ha mai subito
ambulanze eccetera poi mi spiegarono che
era esattamente un blocco psicosomatico
appunto ma era una cosa reale cioè non
riuscivo a muovere a muovermi da pochi
giorni dopo decisi di abbandonare il mio
lavoro e di dedicarmi questa la mia
loquacità diciamo a influenzare le
personalità che conoscevano le
personalità internazionale e produrre
dei cambiamenti intorno questo mi ha
portato in giro per il mondo e mi ha
portato soprattutto a far sì che nei
momenti cruciali alcuni cambiamenti
della storia degli ultimi 20 anni
fossi presente per puro caso e potesse
incidere ad alcuni piccoli cambiamenti
qualcuno purtroppo qualcuno fallito in
altri abbiamo prodotto dei risultati ma
questo questo percorso nasce rompendo il
muro del silenzio dal muro del silenzio
vi voglio portare al muro che non si
conosce che ha un suo legame col
silenzio e il muro che non si conosce
sono i muri dell'africa
l'africa è un continente che è stato
diviso con squadra e compasso nel 1882
noi abbiamo lottato per la nostra
indipendenza tantissime paesi europei
hanno lottato per la propria
indipendenza e le genti hanno deciso il
proprio destino
questo non è toccato ai paesi africani
nel 1882 le potenze bianche occidentali
decidono come doveva essere quel
continenti quel continente interi paesi
sono stati divisi giusto per
per una mediazione politica di interesse
politico economico ma nessuno ha chiesto
a quelle persone e allora vi voglio
raccontare una storia di un paese che
poi ha lottato per la propria
indipendenza e l'ha ottenuta è l'unico
primo paese dell'africa occidentale è il
primo paese africano aveva ottenuto
l'indipendenza durante la seconda guerra
mondiale dal meno un mondiale ed è
appunto il ghana all'ovest del ghana c'è
un territorio tutto oggi c'è un
territorio diviso a metà tra costa
d'avorio e ghana appunto e c'è una tribù
di un milione di abitanti che lungo
tutto questo paese vive metà in costa
d'avorio e metà in ghana perché così è
stato deciso
cento anni fa una parte parla il
francese un'altra parte l'inglese ma la
lingua in sé ma li accomuna e questa
cosa succede tutti i giorni soprattutto
quando da un'altra famiglia in costa
d'avorio si passa il border e si va in
un'altra famiglia in ghana ecco non
dobbiamo più permettere che altri che
anche elementi statua statuali decidano
i confini che invece sono stati decise
dalla natura dalla cultura dalla gente
comune questo non lo dobbiamo più
permettere
ed è per questa ragione che dopo la
seconda guerra mondiale proprio questo
paese divenne l'esempio per tutta
l'africa continentale ma non solo anche
per l'europa su come su come chiedere
un'indipendenza che mettesse la gente al
centro un'inter una indipendenza
pacifica una rivoluzione ed è per questo
che uno dei leader che nessuno conosce
qui in occidente dei leader neri cuamm e
ink roma che veniva proprio da questa
terra ansie ma veniva proprio da questo
confine che soffriva di questa cosa
decisa dagli altri decise di liberare il
proprio paese
con un grandissimo movimento popolare
non violento e ink roma divenne il
simbolo l'esempio per tutti gli afro
americane anche di martin luther king ed
è successo una cosa bellissima
proprio durante l'indipendenza del ghana
il gli stati uniti mandano alla propria
delegazione è la delegazione nella
capeggiata capeggiata da richard nixon
dal vice presidente in carica all'epoca
degli stati uniti e richard nixon
durante i fuochi d'artificio durante la
festa d'indipendenza vedi un uomo nero
davanti a lui e gli disse a sei contento
oggi che il tuo paese finalmente libero
per quest'uomo nero gli rispose ams ore
mi dispiace man from alabama my name is
martin luther king
i due si incontrano no negli stati uniti
ma in un paese africano si conoscono in
un paese africano dove paese che fino
regio per tutta la lotta dei neri
americani
successivamente l'ispirazione sia per
una nuova natura politica del continente
da costruire sia per le lotte sui
diritti civili negli stati uniti nessuno
oggi sa questa cosa perché oggi noi
possiamo scrivere vogliamo scrivere la
storia
solo dalla prospettiva bianca dalla
prospettiva occidentale dalla
prospettiva europea e il muro della
cultura dal battere il moon il muro da
abbattere e una cultura e quello della
cultura razziale e noi ne siamo vittime
ma ne siamo ancora anche gli artefici
voglio parlare di un'altra passo di
pillola in pillola voglio parlarvi di un
altra cosa
passo dall africa mandiamo in asia in
questo momento
attualmente noi stiamo attraversando uno
una delle più grandi crisi umanitaria e
senza che nessuno ci dice niente e della
crisi del popolo ringhia circa quattro
anni fa ormai un milione di rivers di
persone vittime della persecuzione in
germania hanno attraversato il fiume al
confine col bangladesh e si sono
riversate tutte tra lo stato del
bangladesh e e la birmania
si tratta di una striscia molto piccola
dove non esiste uno stato è tra due
stati e queste persone vivevano le una
parte ha naturalmente è stata rifiutata
in in bangladesh ma gran parte ancora lì
e la cosa impressionante che voi vedete
dei microfoni che invitano i militari
che sono continui tar i birmani che sono
col fucile a ritornare indietro in in
birmania e gli altri invece che li
trattengono a stare in questa fascia di
terra senza senza legge e senza nessun
tipo di status e il popolo dero india in
riga sono musulmani e sono perseguitati
in un paese a maggioranza buddista non
di solito noi vediamo esattamente dalle
notizie televisive altro tanto per far
capire come la persecuzione non ha nulla
a che fare con la religione ma
semplicemente a che fare con l'orrore
con la parte buia che presenta in
ciascuno di noi quando si fa teoria e
quando poi si fa azione in questo
contesto sono circa 200mila tra
soprattutto tra uomini e ragazzi e
bambini ad essere stati uccisi
sistematicamente in bangladesh nell'area
dirà chi ne state dove viveva questo
poco da 200 anni che non era mai stato
riconosciuto né dal bangladesh dalla
birmania e questo come l'esempio di
auschwitz come l'esempio della germania
e quello che deve sempre permanentemente
rimanere nella nostra mente
come possiamo trasformare tutta la parte
oscura nella parte di opportunità e
questo
questo ci fa pensare molto e soprattutto
a pensare a che cosa dobbiamo cominciare
a vivere i nostri sogni e qualcuno l'ha
già fatto nel 1968
volevo far vedere la foto fatidica che
ha emozionato tutti sembra una foto oggi
sembra una foto comune perché siamo
abituati al film di fantascienza nel
1968 neil armstrong su dalla luna fa la
prima foto sala prima foto della terra
che sorge è una cosa incredibile
solo il sogno ha permesso alla scienza
di concretizzare la teoria in azione e
quando il sogno e la creatività
diventano azione grazie alla scienza al
concorso di tutta tutto il resto
dell'umanità
nulla è impossibile nulla è impossibile
io posso guardare la terra dalla luna
ecco cosa noi dobbiamo fare ciascuno di
noi ha il potenziale di poter guardare
la terra dalla luna e ciascuno di noi
deve far crescere questo potenziale
all'interno questo è quello che ci
suggeriscono tutte le persone che hanno
combattuto per abbattere il muro di
berlino
tutte le persone che hanno combattuto
anche per fare muro contro leggi le
ingiustizie tutte le persone che
combattono quotidianamente per sfidare i
propri limiti e le proprie impossibilità
impossibilità il sogno il sogno che
diventa realtà e il sogno che un giorno
ciascuno di noi può dire al proprio
figlio alla proprio alla propria bambina
al proprio bambino alla propria moglie
che possono possono creare un mondo un
mondo più giusto pieno pieno di
solidarietà ma soprattutto pieno di
relazione umana
voglio concludere questo mio intervento
con scusatemi con una con un qualcosa
che sintetizza quanto l'elemento della
contraddizione le nostre contraddizioni
noi non dobbiamo rinunciare ad esso ma
quanto la contraddizione sia essenziale
per ripartire e per sognare
vi leggo questo contro di te alzano un
muro in silenzio pietra e calce pietra e
odio
ogni giorno da zone più elevate calano
il filo a piombo i muratori sono tutti
uguali piccoli scuri in faccia maliziosi
sopra il muro segnano giudizi sui doveri
del mondo e se la pioggia di cancella di
riscrivono ancora con geometrie più
ampia ogni tanto qualcuno precipita
dall'impalcatura sv e subito un altro
corre al suo posto non vestono tutti
azzurro
e parlano un gergo allusivo altro il
muro di roccia nei buchi delle trame ora
si infilano jackie e scorpioni pendono
erbe nere l'oscura difesa verticale è
vita da un orizzonte solo i meridiani
della terra e il cielo non lo copre di
là da questo schermo tu non chiede
grazia né confusione salvatore quasimodo
grazia
[Applauso]